where what oh well just gonna ignore
that
hello welcome to three scary games
lixian isn't here right now to spook you
so you've got nothing to worry about so
i'm just gonna leave you with lunky here
and he's gonna guide you into the
beginning of this video take it over
lunky you got this
[Music]
[Applause]
this is never a part it's supposed to be
like
pt but it was created in 48 hours so we
will see
what this is about oh
ah okay
oh lovely hi
clump clump am i supposed to trial the
door
puppy puppy
okay puppy
i'm so scared oh god oh well
all right these cheap tricks ain't gonna
scare me i've seen stuff like this
before
you're gonna have to do something a
little bit more
terrifying
originally was scheduled to serve 15
consecutive life terms in jail
but the judge gave him the death penalty
after confessing to eleven
count em 11 gruesome murders in his own
apartment building
we're talking jeffrey dahmer kind of
stuff here this stuff made ted bundy
look like an amateur
amazingly enough one survivor managed to
escape
and helped lead to his capture this
brave woman escaped his clutches after
he cornered her inside her apartment and
through sheer determination her
craftiness
hell maybe even luck she managed to
injure darren bar and escape
cornered and surrendered
what i didn't quite catch that the
demonic voice i was just there i didn't
quite understand what you were saying
okay fine um elevator
the alabamiader bingbong hello
oh interesting
i see it is
like p t
scary ball hello okay well that's
you're gonna do that again oh yeah you
are gonna do that again
poppy poppy okay
puppy
yeah i agree hilarious puppy
welcome home oh okay thank you poppy
sorrow so cyrus is using the sushi
okay cool
gray is that the killer
no i don't see a puppy here i'm
infinitely disappointed
gotta admit for a 48 hour games they got
a lot of stuff going on here
puppy that's the weirdest puppy i've
ever heard
okay papi you stay good
you stay good puppy you still
i can't move
and this asmr really isn't my taste
uh love what you've done with the place
hi
why why kill your neighbors well
taryn was pretty deranged i mean abuse
when he was younger
a history of erratic demented behavior
through the teens
and then he joined this cult and that's
when things really took off
that's when the remorse left it was a
purpose
it was his calling apparently he needed
all 12 victims
and he was unable to achieve that
because of the
one
am i the one
spy victim was sand something like that
am i the one victim that got away hey i
hurt you before i can hurt you again
emotionally and physically and i don't
know which one of those is gonna be
worse
so you better back off you have another
ball
okay no ball scares no ball horror
no horror balls okay cool ah hey how's
it going
is this my apartment oh there's
crucifixes on the wall
well that's new hi
squeak great good
stuff hello
hi just want to watch the telly
have a good time do we have a note
ah my beautiful boy you will be my last
okay good well if your killing stops
with me
i guess that's a noble sacrifice that i
can make
that's a logical thing i can't be
separated from you
we need each other uh-huh
okay do tell you know death is kind of
the ultimate separator don't come near
me chair
you broke my nose already i won't let it
happen again who's behind me no one
five five years okay five years what
about five years
five years together five years of
pain and torment five years
oh cool good thank you for that
appreciate it big preach biggest preach
actually
oh no oh
not the painting oh it's crooked oh
what have you done no
okay now we're in church
good bad
a gift for me it seems like the worst
things in horror movies
often happen in churches which is
suspect
ah gross i hate it thanks
really appreciate how much i don't like
that
hi where am i oh you sneaky person
a gift for you your
soul that's my face hey how you doing
hey
okay cool the one orchestra violin
didn't know when to stop
oh sorry everyone's done okay all right
well thank you
these presents are delightful they
please me
i am pleased more i say
red orange i correct myself orange
interesting
puppy is that my puppy
am i gonna get a puppy and that puppy
loves to laugh
what someone just clear their throat
yeah they must because they were
prepping to do whatever that was hello
hi okay bye see you around
hi hey
okay
i'm coming for you random murders that
are happening lately
that are similar to the albuquerque
ghoul murders
are they related good darren
rise back up from the dead i i doubt it
whoever it is though they have a
remarkable sense of accuracy i mean it's
almost
scary even details from prior murders
that were never released
are being replicated i don't know guys
albuquerque is looking a little scary
and i truly don't know when the blood
jets
is is that really how you talk about
someone
murdering people
man what accuracy on this murderer
ah man really charming if only they got
it perfect i'm really disappointed
yeah i'm coming for you because even
apart we make a great team
okay great
tell me more i'm you have my curiosity
you only need to get my interest
well this isn't the same i'm
disappointed this is
this is different this is different now
oh
good padded room it was me all
along i'm coming for you because even
apart we make a great team
oh oh
okay oh okay
oh hey uh
oh okay interesting
fascinating
[Music]
oh so another caller asked a great
question
do you think darren was insane insane
for killing those
11 people insane for being this murder
spree
killer uh the serial killer well
it really depends caller on which entity
you believe in
if you want to burn forever then yes if
you want eternal damnation then yes he
was insane
but if you want true salvation if you
want the right thing
if you if you believe in the right thing
then you know he was correct
and honestly caller she ruined it for
everyone
you listening to this radio broadcast
has ruined it for everyone
standing there in that hallway you think
you're going to get away
do you think you could leave us no no
even apart
we make a great team we'll be back
together
i keep looking in the wrong way for the
things to happen
all right okay well um oh
you okay you all right hey there's
someone's still alive in here
you didn't get 11 you got 10.
idiot stupid dummy
what a fool ah
oh ah
well i'll just crawl into my morgue
tray let me just slide on in
can you open one up for me
i can't move
not at all he had the help of a certain
someone special
a certain woman he let escape
you see the news report says that there
were 11 gruesome murders
in fact there were 23 they were just
spaced five years apart
and we're about to finalize the ceremony
welcome to paradise i knew you couldn't
stay away
and even apart we make a great team
oh okay
okay oh
okay oh no now i've killed nobody
[Music]
okay i can't move
oh hey um babe
darling ah schnookums
okay well you know i i like i i was
poking a little fun at it but that was
really well done
for 48 hours there was so much in there
like there was just a lot of stuff
happening a lot of stuff going on they
made that in 48 hours
that's pretty impressive that's really
impressive
that's really nice i mean a lot of it of
course like if you got 48 hours you
can't exactly get
like super intricate stuff there wasn't
like a lot
of over the top incredible
amazing things but it was all just like
a lot of different things happening that
kept grabbing your attention i was very
engaged the whole way through
and like i would like a lot not if a lot
of it scared me too much but
you know still even so it got me a few
times got me a few times that was pretty
good i do appreciate that hey well done
well done all right moving on
oh god i'm going here this is the
punishment for you too
hi this is bisque doll like tomato
bisque
this is what you two get for being close
to our boyfriends
okay a action x
run y menu flashlight battery
laureen ashley am i laureen and i'm
saying ashley
hello
i don't like that oh
battery no that's blood
all right it's not
wait oh pickup is the one in gray
gray is the one selected okay
i'm very confused uh
apparently this is based on some kind of
like folklore
or something like that and also my soul
projects
light a few feet in front of my body
right cool
okay all right this is fine hey use
okay well i had nothing to do about that
all right okay
good great okay there's run
okay corridor
key
of course some seems very
wrong nope nope nope
don't return nope oh return
right open
all right great open
i'm this is fine just everyone give me a
second i need to get
a lot more step sound effects than i
seem to be doing
okay whatever i'm sure this is gonna be
delightful 1b
all right i don't have the key okay
exit all right i don't have the key
starting to sense a pattern here
all right blood which means item
apparently okay
well there's that key and battery
i don't see like a battery meter
okay so i need a key for every door got
it i really don't know what this game is
about
uh just found it it was highly rated
so it kind of seems a little clunky but
maybe i'm just an idiot
okay there's one d did i get that i
didn't hear a click lang
okay it's
it it it's it's strange it's not a lot
happening but i feel
slightly uncomfortable i think i don't
know what i feel
it's probably fine okay whatever
what was it though how did i oops
oh yeah forgot about that
weird okay all right um
god guy i'm at a loss for
oh god that's sensitive okay
sure anyway i got one d
i'm gonna go in one d this is good
let's play does it lock behind me
i wish i could look at that that'd be
great if i could there we go
i don't understand what
okay okay
that's weird cool
cool one me
did i not pick that up pick up
okay there's just a okay
hi
hi i have nothing to say to you
all right ashley
save them
wait a minute
who's them why is them
who are them someone outside this door
better not be coming for you
oh my god
down that
what is happening i hear all the
footsteps
what is going on
i don't like this
what is happening
oh what's with you
i don't like you
oh that's weird
gonna go in here now you know i'm gonna
go in here i have no i'm so confused
if you're confused just think of how
confused i am
hi oh you're moving
oh that's cool are you the ones i'm
supposed to save
i hope not you look fine actually
oh oh i sure wish i could look it there
we go
well this is great this is fantastic
oh my god oh
my god i don't see any of their blood in
here i'm just gonna i'm just gonna go
i'm just gonna go
you freaking balding eight-year-old yeah
you moving closer oh my god they are
oh my god oh my god stop
what do you mean what are you doing
oh my god that was not scary
ah that wasn't even scary why stupid
stupid baloney funny baloney bull crap
all right so now that i know this game i
get that
yeah now that i know this game ain't
actually scary
i could just go do my thing fine
get it get it get it
thank you bisque piece of biscuit
are they back there no they're not back
there so it's all just a ruse
stahl's just a merge trying to play me
for a fool
i think the trick is that when you look
at them they don't move so that's gotta
be it
okay it's this one right oh no it's dead
body
hope it's not my friend is it my friend
thm solving them
uh am i really supposed to be sobbing
the
the little dudes
am i is that who i'm supposed to be
saving or is there someone else in here
like
a students a students you heard me
i think they're moving don't like them
definitely moving okay so i just gotta
be there's something there's gotta be
like
oh my god look oh my god look at them
there's gotta be like something else in
this room that's going to help unlock it
because once i go in here it kind of
just look look
they're not scary they're not they're
not scary it's fine
okay so they're in here but it don't
matter because i'm invulnerable
where was the thing oh god it was over
here wasn't it oh my god look at them
look at them look at them my god
just grab the thing
okay so i is there something else i'm
supposed to do about this
what god the controls are just absurd
controls are absurd is there like a way
to get around him over here or something
oh yeah that's where oh my god i'm gonna
freaking kill you
and they're gonna kill me i'm running
away i'm running away i'm running
oh i don't see oh bro look at them
okay that's what it is okay
use i'm gonna die oh god s a
v a
all right this screw this this this game
is
dumb dave's dumb it didn't scare
me didn't scare me i wasn't scared i
wasn't scared
i wasn't scared at all i wasn't scared
none
i scared exactly zero that's how much
scared i was which is
none fine
moving on this is inside
whoa god whatever this is inside it's
apparently very scary very very scary
not
not the same game as the other one named
inside but this one's
different you don't play as blob monster
grouch jump use
zoom tab c f e email okay
inside is four endings here requirements
for each engine simply escape do not
appear spiritually
collect all diaries click all research
diaries get the suicide weapon escape
cultist break it do the energy a favor
exorcist ending harm the energy escape
all right do not make noise speaking in
real life does not impact the game
bumping into objects makes noise collect
and read diaries to build the story and
read the pages scattering within the
area to help you complete the puzzles
crouch and hide under tables and in
clauses to prevent being seen
your saved progress gets cleared
whenever you get an ending escape
[Music]
lovely corduroy andreas
[Music]
benadez
[Music]
okay well
that's grim
[Music]
inside
[Music]
oh don't like it didn't like that
didn't like that i didn't like that at
all i didn't like that
nun all right four endings huh well i
don't know what i'm gonna do for these
endings i'm just gonna kind of dick
around a little bit that's usually how i
approach it
wake up i'm awake now
hello hi is this my blood
it's a lot of blood
right okay key oh no emf meter i can use
this to detect concentrations of energy
diary so i've been playing around with
these things that seem to have made
themselves at home in my home
i'm not particularly happy about this
but i've been running out of ideas for
my experiments
what better new genre for my experiments
than other than the supernatural
i'm yet to discover a way to effectively
draw the attention of these things but
when i do i will be able to proceed with
this project
okay gotcha all right what is this a
grinder
for what fridge let me get a beer oh
blood let me get a blood sure there's a
lot of blood splattered all over the
place sure
a lot of fridges custom grandfather
clock one clock mechanisms one hour arm
one pendulum
hide it secret compartment am i blinking
or are the lights being weird
okay the energy needs i thought that
said energy drink
needs blood while it's in control of my
body
i need to collect blood i need to feed
the energy it needs to grow i need to
feed
the [ __ ] energy at first i wonder how
the [ __ ] i would be able to feed the
energy while it's inside of me
i mean where can i possible find blood
in masses it's easy
kidnapping of course pool table mod
guide
matcha furniture the following guide
will help you mod your pool table to be
a cool futuristic secret store as it
opens up when you insert a coin
i need to hide it
okay oh okay
well there seems to be plenty of blood
here so i don't know how much i need to
collect
lab key perfect right okay
um oh it's dark
oh it's dark he's dork what is that
table mechanics i found some mechanics
okay
like a person diary it hurts so much
knowing that the love of your life does
not love you anymore i have no idea
what's going on
when it takes over but every time i get
a turn with the body
i'm in agonizing [ __ ] pain i'm
struggling to cope with this
it's my mom said it's my turn with the
body
good it's good it's good it's great
actually actually not that i think about
it it's actually fantastic
what kind of experiments do you do i
know everyone needs a hobby but it's him
frick that was a gunshot
what the [ __ ] this is bad i need to get
the [ __ ] out of here ah
investigate i need to get the hell out
of here okay good what the hell happened
to him
what the [ __ ] is this
okay all right well hold on a second
powerbox key
diary i can't do this anymore i'm
blowing a [ __ ] hole in the body's
head
the pain is umbrella bearable this will
be my final entry
when i'm gone the energy can do as it
pleases i want it to continue living in
the body i just can't take the pain
anymore
i will forever love the energy
the energy okay utter peace this is
wonderful but something doesn't feel
right it feels the energy is trying to
control me but that would be outrageous
we love each other we will forever be
happy
okay yeah and who am i in this
in this uh this lovely adventure who am
i
in this who am i close that door right
there
is locked is locked
i'm ending this project gonzo as a
matter of fact i'm ending all my
projects
double dunzo the energy is all i need
triple dunzo it promised me it would
never leave
it i now belong to it and it belongs to
me
man this energy must be something else
toggle power
i toggled the power i'm looking here now
my head is feeling so relaxed the energy
is not within me
i gave it a body so it can to experience
what it feels like being human
we are now sharing this body i will no
longer be calling it my own body
this is how we will be expressing our
love for each other one body
one love one life
okay wait a minute
hold the phone this carpet is incredible
hold the phone hold that phone
i have the emf emitter in my lab i use
today
i picked up a very strong and bizarre
energy field with it so it's clear
my house is haunted [ __ ] no i don't
believe in ghosts and paranormal [ __ ]
similar to that
it is still strange though this might be
the strange thing i can use for a new
project
where does this energy come from and how
can i use it to draw its attention from
it
benefits wink wink wink when going wink
and stuff like that
benefits you say like
dental that kind of benefit what is with
this weird sprawling house
does this make any sense so many things
our arm okay found that i started a new
project today and yes it's about this
energy
it's quite it's actually quite
interesting to be honest tonight i'll be
sleeping like a baby
i always do after starting a new project
okay what what [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] is that
[Music]
what what what
we're [ __ ] scooting a lot what
what what what are you doing
what was that what
in the world i didn't even use this
what does this mean what does this do
blue
bomb what is this all about
what is this supposed to be what are you
doing starting os i don't know man i
don't know
i don't know i don't know
okay there was something in one of these
drawers god it's going to take forever
to find everything again uh
table mechanics good got table mechanics
you just die you start over again well
that's
stupid
fine whatever it's fine
[Applause]
not happy about that
[Applause]
oh and it's gone okay oh oh it's by the
okay yeah you know what maybe i'll keep
this out just because
maybe it'll get me an idea of what's
coming
all right cool great this is great this
is good
it's great great stuff great this is
good i feel good about this
toggle there we go
bright and vivid
anything in the toilet what the [ __ ] is
in the bathtub uh
um probably fine so [ __ ] bizarre the
energy it feels like it's communicating
with me and it hasn't even been more
than an hour since it seeded to show
itself to me
drain drain it drain it drink it
drain cleaner there we go strain it now
easy peasy lemon squeeze me
i need its key all right cool great
so i've been feeling strange whenever
i'm inside the house i get this weird
vibe i feel strangely addictive
though if i had to describe it i would
certainly use revenge plot like feel
but this is fine since i'm busy seeking
a new and abnormal project
what do you mean you're busy seeking a
new and abnormal project what does that
even mean
what are you talking about oh i didn't
get the coins
oh i'm an idiot i need to go get those
where were those
you gonna come scooting you scooting
where were those
i don't remember right here no not here
ah start a new project kind of weirdo
kind of weirdo are you i'm gonna go in
this closet actually
what does this say hide it
1946
is that like a time for a clock
746 746
i have no idea where were the coins
all right if you're not gonna come
scooting out at me
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god what was that
what did i do i knocked over some chairs
what does that mean
wasn't there something said about not
making noise probably i think i remember
that
okay whatever i ain't afraid of you
i ain't afraid of you where are those
coins i think they were back in the
back in the first room maybe hello
oh my [ __ ] god
oh the corpse is gone eh mysterious
what if i just
close it close the closet close it
hello blah blah blah i'm here
come get me come on hit me
i'm here do it
i want you to do it now he's not gonna
do anything
like a jerk okay what are you doing what
are you doing what are you doing what
are you doing
what are you doing what are you doing oh
he's not there anymore
okay just gotta get to the
where oh i don't know close it oh god oh
ye
gods put it in put in the chips
it's not putting them in they're not
getting put
where am i
oh that looks funny oh it was
hey how you doing
that's weird
what are you doing what are you doing
what are you doing can i get that gun
what if i just
oh my god i almost got the gun you could
have gotten the gun
ooh interesting oh interesting
hey where are you
where'd you go hey why don't you come
out back here
oh give me the gun give me the give me
the gun gun i found the suicide can i
shoot you
scooty okay so he doesn't kill you
easy there he's either easy there
easy there gonna
kaboom just you wait
it's normal this is normal that's normal
you're just gonna come
blasting after me looks like maybe no
looks like i'm free
almost too easy
so can i just leave is lou
that must hurt to walk that way
oh oh i'm dead
it was a little silly it's a little slow
it's a little chilly
it's a little silly i'm gonna give it
one more try but this game is just a
little silly
just a little silly okay
i'm gonna try to find this clock
stuff i guess it's not bad
i'm not i'm not like laughing at it it's
not it's not like terrible the game's
not
bad it's just like it's kind of just the
scooting is
like at first i was i was kind of like
spooked by this game and it's just like
oh i don't know what's happening it's
kind of fun but then the scooting really
changed the dynamic
it really did okay found some mechanics
so there's got to be something in there
i don't know why oh maybe those things
weren't
chips maybe that maybe that was it maybe
i think there were coins like
specifically there were coins right
yeah these are coins not necessarily
chips and i bet there's a difference
okay blam you please
power box investigate okay
let's go get the power box okay that's
law could
i don't know when he comes scooting out
of that door nothing was in here
that one was locked
table mechanics go in here watch out for
the pots
can i look in the couch cushions or
something or i mean good for getting
away from them i guess
is there something under there when it
drains
no drain it uh it takes a while to drain
just close the door and see
maybe something came up there's got to
be a reason right they were there
they wouldn't they wouldn't do this
unless there was something here
hello ah clock key easy i haven't seen a
clock though
where's a clock there's a clock
no idea i need its key yeah well where
is
its key i don't know where its key is i
don't even know what its key is
whatever oh wait have i explored
in here is there stuff in here oh
table chip okay all right
table chip that makes sense right it's
not necessarily like a poker chip it's
like an actual
computer chip insert chip point insert
coin oh my god
i don't know why i felt so shitty this
few hours ago i felt great the energy
has become visible and i'm not in the
mood to researching it but yeah i'll
probably note it in my research tonight
racer what research do you do what
research do you do
times detected scene uh yeah it kind of
looked at me so i guess
um key clock door
oh okay where was that
where what oh well just gonna ignore
that ah
oh my freaking god you
suck oh i run super speed if i go
sideways
for the no it's not that one
okay well that was surprising
but i've got the clock door key but
where is the clock door
i don't know where that be and he's
being a
a stupid okay i'm gonna go bye
oh was it this door this looks like an
exit door though no
well where is it then tried all the
doors
oh here okay
today i woke up with an intense migraine
i do not feel like doing any research
for the day you don't seem to do any
research ever
today i kind of confirmed it was indeed
collections of energy spread throughout
the house at first i thought it was only
concentrated in one specific area
this might also not be very healthy for
me but [ __ ] it i don't care i
enjoy it well what i mean is that the
energy seems to have a bad side effects
like migraines
and probably struggle to sleep like side
effects
insomnia you talking about insomnia
this is locked why is that locked hello
you there
what's down here hello oh
hello okay good i'm not doing any
research
you we're having too much fun we killed
someone's pet today
fun very fun dear cleaning service
please do not touch the grandfather
clock while i'm in russia
what's up real shitty i have a [ __ ]
headache i took the day off today i
think i kind of deserve a day off anyway
you never work
what research are you doing nothing
can't put the hour on don't i have that
clock swing the clock swing part
the pendulum you talking about the pengy
talking about big benji oh well that's
weird
uh i need to go that way
what if i make like a noise you know
what i mean
you know what me mean
funkalonga you coming
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] okay okay okay okay okay close
yeah easy easy easy easy what is this
i always keep my pistol on my body
yep i know that
i'm so relieved i was worked up about
gustav's insult but the energy held me
that [ __ ] dog that kept barking
during the day will no longer be a
problem this might be [ __ ] up but i
don't care killing dog make me feel
better
oh screw this guy look so to me it's not
[ __ ] up it's good i'm actually
enjoying having fun
i'm fun i'm having fun and enjoying it
great good for you man
great i finally identified what these
things are but as usual i can never be
100
certain uh 100 specifically there's a
great chance my discovery is faulty
therefore i can safely assume that i've
discovered that these things appear to
be collections of energy spread
throughout my home
when i enter one of these areas my
closing receives a charge or says some
say
i can shock someone it's not very useful
for me side effect caused by these areas
might include insomnia and headaches i'm
not having any difficulty sleeping and
my head feels fine so the siri
you have to be proven what what did that
say
guest room closet oh yeah that closet
okay you there i'm going for it screw
you
screw you screw you screw you screw all
of you grew all of you
all of you every one of you open nice
clock mechanics love it love this love
it love this mechanics pendulum
our arm well i guess i need a minute arm
okay i'm kind of at an impasse here
oh my god this door here ain't open
was there something else in here
i'm in love why it loves me back and
never promised to leave me
wow in here maybe
oh ow oh i didn't ha i forgot i didn't
pick it up again
oh my god holy [ __ ] don't do that
what are you doing what are you doing
what are you doing okay there was
something else right
side i don't know whatever
good god stop that weirdo
okay well now i'm at an impasse because
i really don't have any idea
it was um this door here but that one
doesn't work
i don't know seems like a whole lot of
nothing
that's weird
oh my god you're still there oh well
[Music]
they're squatting down all right um i'm
gonna leave that one there
it's it i like it's not bad it's pretty
formulaic in terms of what
you're doing um especially considering
every everything's in the same place
the mechanics of the the monster are
just like
random exploration to try to run away
from that but still it did scare me so i
got to give it that did this scare me
and there's like
apparently four endings so that's that's
something
that that is something there's really
nothing that i can criticize about that
so
if you want to play this link is in the
description all right so that's all for
three scary games don't worry
i'm not gonna make lunky uh watch you
as the video ends i've put him away
he shouldn't be a bother to anybody
anymore
so thank you everybody so much for
watching if you got more scary games
that you want me to play let me know in
the comments